Mrs. Greenfield
alerted the entire world
by way of the social media web
that she'd be meeting
some girlfriends
for '90s trivia night
at this local bar.
Hey there, do you guys mind
if I join your team?
I'm sorry. It's just kind of
a girl power kind of night.
Can you scooch over
just a little bit there?
It's just us ladies.
Mind giving a little bit
of room there?
You know, you'd probably
be more comfortable
if you kept scooching over just
elbow room-wise--good, okay.
(Forrest)
Although this predatory behavior
felt wrong on many levels,
I knew I had to continue,
for the good of humanity.
I've been brushing up
on the '90s.
I know all about, you know,
Diff'rent Strokes and Webster.
I think that was the--
that's the '80s.
Nancy Reagan's
"Just say no" thing,
reading up on that
last night.
That's the '80s as well.
And the various people
that got involved,
you know, with that.
In the movie Office Space,
what item did Peter pull
from the rubble?
- Yes.
- Red scissors.
- No. Anybody else?
- Red stapler.
Yes, red stapler.
What's the difference?
It's the same thing.
Um, one's staples,
one's a scissor.
Can we get half credit
for that?
- No, you don't. No.
- You got the--
She--
Well, you got the color right.
- You got the color right.
- It's fine.
(Forrest)
I paid a lot of special
attention to Mrs. Greenfield.
Yes.
How did you know that?
I watched a ton
of Soul Train.
That is amazing.
(Forrest)
And thanks to alcohol
and flattery,
I was making
surprisingly good progress.
Wow, that's great, so you've got
now just the two cats.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
(Forrest)
As the night wore on
and her friends left the bar,
sex with Mrs. Greenfield
seemed more and more likely.
So what's your story,
mystery man...
Hmm, oh, well...
With you in the middle
of nowhere?
Oh, I live in Hollywood,
California, actually.
(Forrest)
My knowledge that
Mrs. Greenfield had minored
in drama
was a valuable asset.
Has anybody ever told you
that you should actress?
You mean be a, like,
be an actress?
Be an actress, yeah.
Well, I am one.
- I do teach, but, like...
- Okay.
I also actress.
Do you really?
I think I should
switch to waters.
- I'm gonna switch to water.
- Oh, no, no, no.
No, you don't, sir.
I'm gonna buy you
a pitcher.
- What? A pitcher?
- Yes. Here we go.
(Forrest)
As our evening progressed,
I saw that Mrs. Greenfield
was a dreamer being held back by
a distant and uncaring spouse,
and that moved me greatly.
Just pull it off.
(Forrest)
That night,
I had truly glorious sex
with Mrs. Greenfield.
Though I do not know
what she's like in a classroom,
in bed,
she is a gifted teacher,
revealing to me
sexual positions
that have broadened my horizons
and expanded my mind.
It was amazing.
My review might
have ended here
but for
a surprising development.
Sounds like a fun activity.
Mrs. Greenfield?
- Oh, hi, Stephen.
- Oh.
This is Stephen.
Yes. Hello.
- I didn't mean it like that.
- Oh.
Well, I don't know,
uh, who you are
or w-what you could ever mean
- by that or anything else.
- Okay.
- So yeah.
- It was good to run into you.
- We'll see you later.
- Very good. Okay.
Hey, I meant your teacher,
not my teacher.
I don't have a teacher.
I'm a grown-up, so I couldn't
have done that, okay?
Yeah, screw you.
And your show sucks.
Come on.
- Do not engage with him.
- What?
(Mrs. Greenfield)
He is off.
(Forrest)
No, he's just a nice young man.
Well, an awkward ending
to a very enjoyable experience.
Stephen, I'm sorry.
It couldn't have been easy
watching me make beautiful
and athletic love
to the woman of your dreams.